parfois quand on est miss et qu'il y a
des mains qui commence la descente ou
même même juste un contact physique ou
alors les des gens qui vous met des
mains paopao fait ce nom j'écrase les
pieds en général avant que ça arrive un
oui c'est vrai mais bien sûr mais il
n'ya pas que les miss qui sont concernés
ou c'est comme sur les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui cantons le soin un nude et
où d'un gars quand vous voyez ça mais
qu'on connaît ni d'ève ni d'adam avec la
photo au bail elle est là et puis bah
clairement cesser son anatomie masculine
diminué qui apparaît quand vous parlez
de main baladeuse c'est ça c'était dans
l'année miss france dans la nuit ce sens
principalement oui et ça a été jusqu où
la pire des fois à la taille n'en faut
comme ça la clé wes qu'après vous vous
défendez tout de suite alors moi la
prochaine fois je sais que je marcher
sur les pieds de bernard montiel est
souvent la petite m'a baladé sur les
faits selon la brique ou non mais oui
sexy non déneigée les alors vous avez
été miss france ou alors vous avez fait
des fois vous êtes faits disent les
voilà avec des photos et alors les mains
baladeuses
oui c'est pas une légende le pire c'est
que moi j'ai eu un homme politique qui
était derrière moi alors on m'a dit ça
et on m'a dit tu vas devoir lui faire
dire en plateau le nom de l'homme
politique aurait jamais gauche ou droite
on va faire un imminent mais gilles
régis il est de droite
c'est tous cas pas le droit certaines
s'étaient alors il est toujours mariée
il est environ sur marié donc je ne veux
pas détruire sa famille surtout qui ne
s'est jamais rien passé alors qu'il
m'apprenne n'a pas été président et les
pendants alors qu'il m'a utilement
rappaz alors qui m'a pratiquement
harcelé pendant six mois personne mais à
l'époque il y avait il n'y avait pas de
portable
non mais ça y sa veine on ya passé il
avait déjà cédé 1,87 m excuse moi ainsi
si j'avais mon truc
j'avais un grand truc 85,87 une
indication 87
on a commencé à chercher 85 hommes
politiques de droite encore marié et
papa mort il quitte donc il vous appelez
donc le deux fois les gars là que je que
je faisais avec madame de fontenay parce
qu'on allait en alsace pour failli sont
miss alsace et donc chaque fois il
savait où je maîtrisais tous les jours
j'avais un bouquet de fleurs à l'hôtel
il essayé de m'appeler donc je je je ne
prenais jamais son appel parce que
j'étais encore une petite gamine et ma
tempe droite en alsace chercher mon avis
je refuse chacun ses goûts j'ai refusé
et puis oui sinon j'ai aussi reçu
des slips parce qu'à l'époque pc wii et
slip kangourou les dames aussi c'est ce
que porte à oui comment tu sais ça
dissipe
ouais des slips d'hommes et beaucoup de
demandes de mariage alors ça a
énormément mais là je recevais par
courrier parce qu'on n'avait pas les
miens qui m'a dit aussi une gamine qui
était persuadé que j'étais sa mère voilà
c'est tout mignon ça c'est plus mignon
oui mais bon c'est terrible de la
terrible pas de photo on va d'abord mis
des photos coquines 15e à la main mais
ça plein plein puis des photos de sexe
masculin sexe ou alors aussi et des
femmes aussi un jeu c'est avec leurs
poitrines femme aussi pourtant c'est en
c'était son bien et aussi en sortant de
gala il ya des hommes qui me demandaient
des fois d'écrire un petit coeur sur
leur torse la la la la critique on fait
souvent omis france est de dire que les
miss sont un peu femme objet on va pas
se mentir c'est un peu vrai dans le pôle
années de règne
photo j non mais bon vous êtes approché
un peu tripoter non mais attends mais on
laisse tomber le stuff pourquoi mais
bien sûr mais cc by a pas que les miss
france qui sont non mais non non vous
n'êtes jamais fait approcher un jeu ou
si vous êtes à hauteur de kyoto de tout
le monde
alors forcément les malades c'est parce
que c'est trop petit on n'a jamais
arrivé dès fois dans une soirée à machin
est alors mal
il s'est alors là joseph une fois tout
jamais il y avait une seule chose une
seule chose en boîte de nuit un peu un
peu particulière voilà mais mais mais
mais mais voilà c'est tout je raconterai
faire avec cyril la connaître non non
c'était un homme